the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video all right my
friends in this video i will be
discussing the upcoming release of hbo's
new game of thrones series house of the
dragon as you all know hbo has been
developing this new game of thrones
series for a number of years like game
of thrones house of the dragon will be
set within george rr martin's a song of
ice and fire universe this show will
focus on what happened during the dance
of dragons when house targaryen went to
war with each other over the iron throne
and the line of succession
the events surrounding the dance of
dragons happened over a hundred years
before the main events in game of
thrones you can read about them in
george rr martin's novel fire and blood
vol 1. now some of you might not know
this but house of the dragon was
recently rated as the most highly
anticipated show of the year even with
the divisive ending in game of thrones
there are millions of fans still dying
to see what hbo does with their
follow-up show set in westeros one of
the main things fans are wanting to know
is when will we actually see house of
the dragon now we have all heard it will
release this year but how much longer do
we have to wait well from most of the
accounts i have seen it does look like
hbo is done filming the first season of
house of the dragon now they might still
have to do some reshoots here and there
but it does sound like most of the cast
and crew are done we have seen various
members of the cast announce that they
are done filming but the cast members
are rarely on set for the whole shoot
anyway the real sign the filming is
wrapping up is when the crew starts to
say their goodbyes on social media and
the house of the dragons account has
been recording some of those messages
one of them says today was my last day
on a production that was simply amazing
you can even see their house of the
dragon season one jacket and the photo
they shared
one of the other messages says that's a
wrap after eight long but amazing months
and another message says my last day on
game of thrones will anyone ever call it
by its new name meaning house of the
dragon
so it sounds like just about everyone is
done filming season 1. they are at the
very least winding down on set
now even if they are done filming
everything there is still a lot of work
that needs to be done with a show that
will feature over a dozen different
dragons the amount of effects that will
need to be added is insane
especially when you consider how amazing
the dragons always looked in game of
thrones as you all know some of the
dragon scenes and game of thrones looked
far better than the ones you would see
in major films
those effects alone could be several
months of work for all we know now if
any of you are familiar with hbo and how
they rolled out each season of game of
thrones then you know that most of the
seasons would release during the month
of april as a matter of fact six out of
the eight seasons of game of thrones was
released during that month so i would
like to think that hbo would do
something similar with house of the
dragon however since this show does have
so many dragons that date might not be
realistic
now with that being said something very
interesting did happen recently
regarding house of the dragon's release
date in a recent write-up in the german
magazine tv movie they said house of the
dragon will be out in the fall or winter
of this year now i don't know where or
how they got this information hbo hasn't
made an official announcement of their
own but maybe they know something we
don't as of right now there is no
confirmed release date for house of the
dragon's first season but i would like
to think they will have it out by this
summer since no game of thrones season
ever released during the fall or winter
months if it's not out by this april
then i would say june or july would be
my next guess for now we will just have
to wait and see what happens
like i always say you will know as soon
as i know because whenever i find out
something new i always release a video
letting everyone know what's happening
next if any of you like staying up to
date on any and all information
regarding game of thrones house of the
dragon and a song of ice and fire make
sure you subscribe now
we might be getting house of the
dragon's first official trailer very
soon and you won't want to miss my
breakdown and analysis of each and every
frame we see as always i want to thank
everyone for watching this video i hope
i will see all of you back here for my
next one have a great day everybody i
will see you soon bye
um
[Music]
you